david
four-month-old leilani solomon died from
what the coroner's office said was
secondhand smoke from her parents
smoking meth or meth residue that was on
her parents hands now her dad who isn't
supposed to be using any drugs is
accused of violating his terms of
release at least a half dozen times
a positive test on december 13th of this
year
judge harmony letizia begins to read off
the times 24 year old brian carroll
scram bracelet alerted house arrest to
meth in his system in all carroll is
accused of using meth six times in the
last four months one of the main
conditions of his release
was that he was tabored with drug
testing and obviously given the nature
of the charges that he was
remain clean carol and the baby's mother
evangelina solomon faced child abuse
charges all in connection with their
four-month-old daughter's death in 2020.
carol telling investigators he and
solomon used meth together
sometimes getting high in a bathroom
adjacent to a bedroom where they left
their child the coroner's office ruling
the baby died from meth toxicity from
either second hand smoke or trace
amounts of meth on her parents hands in
court monday carol's attorney said his
client was adamant he was not using but
the judge wasn't having that ordering
him back to jail obviously given the
circumstances of this case
the fact that a child died due to
methamphetamine
overdose
at the hands of mr carroll and solomon i
do think it's appropriate to romantic
custody without bail
his death
is her cause of her manner of death that
is is undetermined her cause of death
was toxicity meth toxicity both parents
do back in court next week where they
will accept a plea deal that we've
learned involves prison time i'm david
charns live local now